good morning Hank it's Tuesday December
1st which means it's no longer Movember
which means I can finally frakking shave
which I will be doing over the course of
this video movie magic
[Music]
so Mike lately I've been feeling like my
life is completely out of control you
know how it is you had a few things slip
because you're busy and overwhelmed and
then one day you look up and you're like
oh my goodness I am a failed state of a
person sometimes you look at your life
and you don't even know where to start
making changes now Hank multiply that
problem times 180 million that's
Pakistan where to even start public
education Pakistan has a 40% of literacy
rate although it's dropping steadily and
for many families the only real
educational opportunity available to
their kids are at these mod races where
they spend all their time reading the
Quran without apparently ever reading
the parts where it talks about killing
women and children always being wrong
these modders by the way are all paid
for with Saudi oil money which you know
used to be our money so good on us so
education not good right now economics
slightly better Pakistan's economy has
been growing in the last few years
although the per capita GDP by
purchasing power is less than a thousand
dollars a year to radically oversimplify
that number on average people in
Pakistan live on less than $3 a day the
military strong to strong some might
argue the military is the only public
institution in Pakistan that people
trust and historically the military
likes to use that trust by throwing the
occasional coup but basically the reason
people trust the military and they don't
trust any other facet of the government
is that the military in Pakistan does
stuff like for instance the military is
trying to root out Taliban elements from
the Northwest part of Pakistan and even
though that war is unpopular in Pakistan
and seen as kind of unwinnable people
are still more likely to trust the
military than anybody else because at
least the military has like an agenda by
the way Hank I don't know if you've
noticed but I isolated a piece of cheek
beard it's like a hairy dimple what else
are government supposed to do roads the
Pakistani government is not good at that
police forces boy are they not good at
that one of the big problems in Pakistan
is that you can pass laws there's just
no way to enforce them and in Pakistan
right now there's just no political
leadership to change any of this the
President of Pakistan is the widower of
Benazir Bhutto who while certainly
controversial had at least some
political talent and was therefore
fascinated in late 2007 because the
Pakistani Taliban is always killing
talented politicians so now Pakistan has
a president whose primary qualification
is that he was once married to someone
and then there's no one good waiting in
the wings because I mean let's face it
would you want to be President of
Pakistan Hank there's like a 40% death
rate the Discovery Channel should make a
reality show about the dangers of that
job and so this is the conundrum the
rest of the world finds itself in here
is a nation with nuclear weapons and a
hundred eighty million people a nation
that borders both the world's largest
democracy and one of the fastest-growing
countries in India and crazypants
Afghanistan people want to help but
where do you start do you start with
education or infrastructure or trying to
limit corruption nobody knows everyone's
paralyzed and in the meantime the
Pakistani Taliban keep killing moderate
political leaders so that's my non
rhetorical question for the day
nerdfighters where do you start and now
Hank I announce your punishment I might
just keep it like this so Hank a
mathematically inclined nerdfighter
figured out that the extra two seconds
in the video for which you are being
punished cost the community of
nerdfighteria a total of 26 hours
because it was watched like 55 thousand
times well Hank we won our 26 hours back
in your hometown of Missoula Montana
there is a target that target opens at 8
o'clock in the morning you will be there
when it opens and you my dear brother
will be there when it closes 15 hours
later and in the interim you will not
leave the target I wanted you to stay in
the target for the entire 26 hours but
apparently the target in Missoula
Montana closes which is unfortunate so
to make up for the 11 hour difference
you're going to have to do a second
punishment while you're spending your 15
uninterrupted hours and target you'll
purchase a blender you will take that
blender to the target restaurant where
you will publicly blend the meal of your
choice and then eat it or drink it
depending on your perspective Hank I'll
see you tomorrow mustache